whenever i say women's training needs to
be different than men like
we can train as hard as guys like if
anything i i think the women can train
harder
some of the workouts i've seen people do
like we can grind
um but there are certain things that are
different
and need to be accounted for like even
just the fact that over the course of a
four week period of time like
there are so many studies about like if
you're in your pms week
bluntly you're probably not going to be
performing quite as well
and that doesn't mean you shouldn't push
through and sometimes you know
kind of continue to like grind
um but there should be this
acknowledgement that okay maybe the
sort of times we're targeting this week
can be a little adjusted or
if you're in a program that like builds
for three weeks and drops for a week
maybe if we try to align that with that
week that would be more beneficial
so like super kind of sciency oriented
opportunities are something that very
very few people talk
about um but the other thing is that
for women how we're built physically and
how we develop
um you know guys it's just like an
upward trajectory perpetually
it's like yeah it's pretty
straightforward girls there's there's
always that
kind of college year slump and that's
you know that's okay
like that's just a thing and maybe one
girl doesn't experience
that maybe one girl hits it really
really hard um
but if you're like lifted through that
and you're supported through that
then you're gonna get to 22 and then
you're gonna have that kind of like
resurgence of um you know
kind of like knowing your body and your
body kind of being in this
space where like it's done yeah well
there's a later peak to it
right and understanding that there's
going to be peaks and valleys through
those interim years and not making a big
to-do about
that or having it be a referendum on how
the rest of your career is going to play
out i think is really important and i
think
that change only happens when you are
staffing these
teams with women coaches and women
psycho you know it's like you got to
have people
who understand this yes who can help
these young women
through this process and not hold them
to expectations that are ultimately not
in their long-term best interests as an
athlete
exactly because i think one thing too is
that you know
all of the issues that i've spoken about
like reds
relative energy deficiency and sport
which is essentially when you're
under fueling and or over training and
or therefore developing
um you know different physical reactions
such as bone loss
um men can experience that as well
but the bar at which you start to break
down
is like easier for women to hit and it's
because physically we're supposed to
carry a little bit more fat
where you know we have this almost um
like like our fail-safe of like
reproductive health is going to drop
before
a man's does and as a result we almost
like it's not that we can't push
ourselves as hard
but going over the red line um
too often is more risky and there's more
opportunities for things to start to
break down just
because biologically we're different and
i think
that's why like having people
who understand and can relate
and sympathize and have their own
experiences such as other female coaches
or
support staff is always going to be
helpful
but it's also incredibly important so
that the men who are
also in those positions and also want to
be coaching or support staff
do the work and put in the time and
educate themselves and
i think that's can be said about so many
different things like
just as we need more women in sport
we need more diverse individuals getting
these positions
and i always say that any culture
that supports inclusivity and supports
diversity
and supports this ability to have
different opinions in a room and
different experiences in a room and
backgrounds
is always going to be a better culture
than one
in which it's just one type of person
so for as much as we need more women we
we also need more people of
all sorts of backgrounds being able to
be in those positions because
that just ability to find ways to relate
um with one another and it's just super
[Music]
powerful
[Music]
so
[Music]
you